state's post office open for passport
applications but in-person services
really limited they're not accepting
walk-ins they require advanced
appointments not leaving a whole lot of
travelers frustrated right so mary jane
ballista shares the other options that
are available for travelers who are
looking to get a passport
be prepared and don't wait last minute
to get a passport that's the message
from the united states post office as
they bounced back from employee
shortages and a backlog of passport
appointments that stemmed from the
pandemic i've been seeing a lot of
people having a hard time making the
appointment to get the
applications
submitted abby lagman president of
blissful travel company helps plan
vacations she says to expect advanced
appointments at least three weeks out or
more i am seeing maximum processing time
for the passports as well so i think
they're trying to find ways to make it
go a little smoother or faster
but it's still
you know i think we're still kind of
catching up from covid and
and the processing from then but the
post office isn't the only place you can
get an appointment this includes a
southern nevada health district the
clark county commission office and the
windmill library that's where nick
layman went you make an appointment on
the first day of the month
starting at 9 30 through an online
portal pick your spot it was super easy
i was glad that there were more options
out there
i think it's neat that different
businesses are
doing different stuff so it's not just
the post office so yeah my experience
was amazing
hopefully this will help other people do
it routine processing times for a
passport can be up to eight to 11 weeks
mary june belliesa 8 news now
now usps says quote passport demand is
considerable at this moment as customers
in las vegas and across the country
enjoy travel opportunities and we are
working to increase passport application
availability